oh yeah man Canadian wife will scare me
a little bit not as nice as I thought
you would be I thought much you're all
being like a lot of this guy classy all
right kind of French but not really
[Laughter]
[Music]
- back down your [ __ ] land for the
rest of the show that is contagious and
you keep that corona as lamp oh no
laughs son you're sure - the most
contagious I want that don't you dare
suppress it [ __ ] that yo we don't test
down here for this corner lab I'm
American all right gonna spread that
[ __ ] around we'll deal with it later
you got the greatest land in the history
of laughs oh my god that was like a
[ __ ] orgasm no this guy right there
is one guy come on 100 times that's
crazy oh don't be shy about it
promise me when we sell times about that
land that's the best life ever
buddy you're [ __ ] adorable [ __ ]
just for you
don't worry god I feel great you get to
make a bad decision or to you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hey can I see what intimate question
you know you're all wanting over right
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm letting you ask you if you want to
know what do you want to know about this
guy but this is sex life there's a
question we all want to help because I'm
very curious about nothing like keeping
ranking in his [ __ ] it work you know
you got a fan you got a man you do do
you guys live together know who that
goes to whose house when it's time to
get down Bobby's name like they're
coming to your [ __ ] house I try to do
this to my [ __ ] apartment
this gun he probably heard it from the
next town over yo is it the first time
he's ever won do they like you I imagine
not
Jesus Christ what Doug did you have to
build the jerk off anybody you had to
have a safe house for masturbation and
this crazy scheme has gotta move anytime
I wasn't come around is the father your
dad did that on purpose he was trying to
interrupt maybe he's not approving of
your lifestyle because he was just like
your dad to walk in on you he did that
[ __ ] on purpose there he was zero
surprise in his mind he heard you coming
from literally from easy easily here on
the base he's on the third floor
[Music]
and your homegirl is who says he's a
friend your sister look your best friend
okay so she knows yeah what does he say
about it not him you're an another
friend
it means cute how long have they been
together a year so yeah
you know what I really and I hope you
guys make it out to get married you're
[ __ ] launch if you love this dude but
I do want to know in four years how does
he feel about a lot of [ __ ] that my girl
thought I did was cute it's been four
years and now she's sick and tired man
that's a great man always though good
for you
I'm serious that is no lives the best
lamb I've ever in my life I can't
believe this you go through a whole life
like that
what are you for this
[Applause]
[Laughter]